i spend all this time on this not only
because it's interesting to figure out
how human beings emerged from primates
but also because i think a full teasing
apart
of of how that happened will set up
signposts for how we might find
our way out of the the nightmare
of modernity we now have an enormous
cultural momentum built up behind
these lethal social styles and behaviors
like male dominance like environmental
destruction
product fetishism materialism
ego ego and ego
all of this is is tremendously
exacerbated by modern civilization
and if we had a thousand years
to work this out we might be able to
save ourselves from armageddon without
recourse
to the original sacraments and the
original chemical
uh symbiosis
but given that we probably have 40 or 50
years
i think we need to think about the role
these things played in
early human development i'm not the
first person to
put this together i mean i've done it in
high detail and with psilocybin
but 20 years ago in a book called the
ghost in the machine
arthur kessler observed that we
human beings he didn't single out the
males
but we human beings are hardwired for
murder that's what we do best is
bash each other's brains out and and
that was
fine for the middle stone age but it's
entirely inappropriate in a global
society and he suggested pharmacological
intervention
he was thinking in terms of some kind of
tranquilizer or something like that
i think we need to genuflect a little
more deeply to the heights of human
nature
as well as to the depths and i think it
is
very interesting that in 1953
the watsons uh exploring one of the last
unexplored or you know very little
contacted areas of the new world
came upon what they called the mushroom
religion or the mushroom sacrament but
what in fact
operationally was the body of eros
sleeping since metaphorically the fall
of atlantis
sleeping there in the mexican highlands
they brought it back to modern
civilization
and now groups like this
small groups of people individuals
taking psilocybin
anthropologists who in the last hundred
years have brought the news
of the use of plantalucinogens in many
aboriginal cultures
all of this data information technology
and plants
fungi arriving on the plate
of western civilization at the same time
and you know as h.g wells said history
and he meant western history
is a race between education and
catastrophe
it's going to be a photo finish folks
and my interest in this field
is because this is the only and by this
i mean the hallucinogenic plants
are the only factor i've ever seen
that would turn an individual around
in about six and a half hours from being
you know a jerk to being someone who at
least had the concept that it would be
nice to
be a decent human being and
it's a a
mass turning of that sort
is probably the only thing which will
save us
from the cultural juggernaut
that we have set in motion over the past
couple of thousand years
i don't expect us to start herding our
cattle across
the plains of africa again that's
gone forever but there must be
ways that we can overcome our
obsession with male dominance monotheism
sexual exclusivity product fetishism
so forth and so on and i think the way
through
is to let the mushrooms
speak through us of
the um the agenda of the guy and mind
because that's what it was that's what
the mushroom message was in pre-history
it was a message of accommodation
that allowed poetry theater humor
mathematics
human hope human fear and disappointment
to coexist
with the larger concerns of the rest of
the living earth
in a relationship of dynamic respect
rather than a relationship of of
rape plunder and mass destruction which
has characterized
the monotheistic monogamistic
scientific phonetic alphabet driven
dysfunctional civilizations that arose
once the connection with the mushroom
was
was broken
[Music]
you